c'est un procès très attendu celui des
opposants au projet d'enfouissement des
déchets nucléaires à bure dans la meuse
sept d'entre eux comparaissent
aujourd'hui si pendant trois jours
devant le tribunal correctionnel de
bar-le-duc pour association de
malfaiteurs détention de produits
incendiaires et violence notre reporter
qu'elle pique sur place des
centaines de militants et autres
soutiens sont venus aujourd'hui devant
le palais de justice de bar le duc
ils viennent à accompagner les militants
contre le site de déchets radioactifs de
bure le projet cigéo ils sont venus
faire un défilé aujourd'hui dans les
rues de bar-le-duc ses sept prévenus
sont sous le coup d'un chef
d'inculpation l'association de
malfaiteurs un terme qui a beaucoup fait
réagir ou qu'il aura attiré le soutien
nombreux écrivains intellectuels
politiques tous propose d'écouter
michèle rivasi eurodéputée écologiste
qui est venu aujourd'hui avant le dic
moi même
voyez j'ai été député de l'assemblée
nationale je suis allé visiter plein
site de stockage et tous ont eu des
problèmes
puis s'assoit weepu il ya eu un incendie
que ça soit yucca mountain sur où il ya
eu des infiltrations d'eau que ce soit
en allemagne il n'y a pas de solution en
enfouissement souterrain c'est trop
compliqué à gérer
et là on veut nous faire croire et
d'ailleurs on n'a toujours pas
l'inventaire de tous les déchets qu'on
va mettre en grande profondeur
ça va être des centaines d'hectares
souterrain et il faut absolument qu en
france on instaure ce débat et qu'on
nous oblige pas par un acte autoritaire
a accepté ce site de stockage
un petit rappel des faits la lutte à
burg a commencé en 95 avec un projet de
laboratoire qui s'est avéré être un
projet gigantesque site de stockage de
déchets radioactifs à partir de 2016 la
lutte s'est intensifiée et
répression dix militants a commencé
c'est à dire que dans cette affaire il
ya eu 29 personnes sur écoute 95000
conversation interceptée le nombreuses
perquisitions des surveillances
multiples et variables à tel point que
la ligue des droits de l'homme a dénoncé
un harcèlement des militants par les
autorités publiques
les avocats dénoncent le fait que l'on
reproche à leurs clients de ne pas avoir
pu ignorer que des dégradations elle
être commis dans une manifestation doute
2017 et ceci au culte leur véritable
lutte surjus propose d'écouter un des
avocats d'un des prévenus point de vue
de la loi
nos clients pour une peine de dix années
d'emprisonnement ce qui apparaît
effectivement extrêmement lourd et il
grave du point de vue de la loi mais
effectivement les faits qui sont in fine
et ce sont des faits qui tourne autour
de l'organisation d'une manifestation le
15 août c'est essentiellement ça qu'on
juge c'est à dire que finalement on se
retrouve avec un procès après trois ans
d'instruction pour juger une
manifestation et voir ce qui s'est passé
n'ont même pas au cours de cette
manifestation mais pour ce qui s'est
passé en amont de cette manifestation
ce que nous attendons de ce procès c'est
évidemment que l'accusation
d'association de malfaiteurs sortent en
éclats parce qu'elle ne tient pas et que
ce n'est qu'un moyen de nuire à la lutte
paie
qui peut même les opposants le procès va
durer jusqu'au 3 juin les militants
encourent jusqu'à douze ans de prison
en tout cas ici les associations attac
greenpeace tous les militants estiment
qu'il devrait être relaxé